je vais à peine 8 ans j'allais aider mon
père dont resteront là où travaille m et
le patron l'époque était monsieur
monsieur vincent mallet donné cinq
fronts une pièce de 5 francs et avec ses
5 francs mais je me suis acheté une
boîte de lego je me rappelle toujours me
rappellerai toujours c'était un
hélicoptère rouge cette petite boîte qui
à partir de labège et mais a au delà de
pouvoir passer du temps avec mon père
mais j'allais travailler pour avoir
cette petite récompense qui me
permettait à chaque fois de de
renouveler ma gamme de lego c'est très
drôle mais je crois que ça m'a marqué
vraiment mes parents ne m'ont jamais
donné d'argent de poche
jamais ils m'ont toujours dit tu veux
quelque chose battue va le gagner ont
travaillé au restaurant de mes parents
justement et on avait comme comme
salaire mais si on est à l'école mais
les pourboires des clients donc c'était
au bon vouloir des clients nous paie
donc il fallait que ma soeur on saleh
soual soit bien soit agréable et puis
que non puis don soit efficace et on
soit bon aussi meilleur ouvrier de
france en 2000 alors ça ça a été une
expérience incroyable chez mon meilleur
ami michel portos ce qui me dit philippe
tu veux pas qu'on passe les mof tous les
deux bagis ouais ce qu'il veut et je me
suis donné à fond pendant un an sur sur
ce concours sur leurs recettes qu'on
avait à travailler et à aucun moment
j'ai lâché donc il y avait beaucoup de
travail en amont
je travaille beaucoup la journée je
m'entraîne et le soir la nuit j'avais
pas beaucoup de moyens non plus et comme
quoi voilà on peut y arriver aussi avec
peu de moyens mais avec beaucoup de
beaucoup d'engagement et du courage
aussi et l'abnégation et il se trouve
que je devais subir une opération à une
opération du coeur j'ai subi une
opération du coeur entre les demi
finales et la finale est le jour de la
finale j'étais sous anticoagulants je ne
savais pas ce que c'était que de se
couper quand on est sous anticoagulants
et le premier quart d'heure de la finale
je me coupe le doigt mais bien comme il
faut avec le désosseur est en train de
faire et canards et l'âge et le doigt et
sans qu'ils puissent non mais sous l'eau
j'avais prévu des pansements au cas où
je me mets les p'tits pansements sofres
est n'est pas c'était pas cher ça
faisait que pi c et g l'un des membres
du jury qui a vu le petit problème que
jamais il m'a amené d'autres pansements
et des petits des petits doigts en
caoutchouc là pour pouvoir compenser
tout ça donc j'ai pas été je me suis pas
déstabiliser non plus il faut il faut
pas l'être pour ça que le mental et
compte beaucoup dans un concours j'ai eu
ce titre c'était un défi que je m'étais
lancé
j'en faisais pas une gloire personnelle
et d'ailleurs même j'ai mis du temps à
porter cette veste parce que je je sais
pas pourquoi je me sentais pas légitime
d'être meilleur ouvrier de france
je pense qu'on n'est pas meilleur
ouvrier de france après un concours je
pense qu'on le devient avec le temps
[Musique]
le 8 septembre 2015 je peux vous le dire
je m'en rappellerai de cette date là je
n'ai jamais eu aussi peur de ma vie
pourtant j'en ai fait des choses je
voulais raconter je vais je fais du
sport je sais match dur chez combat de
boxe combat de séduire la boxe sa
demande ça demande aussi beaucoup de
courage et un gros mental
mais là mon premier restaurant
j'en ai pas dormi pendant trois jours et
ça ne m'était jamais arrivé et le jour j
je monte en salle se décline son
sous-sol jeunes en salle pour faire le
débrief avec la salle une heure avant
l'ouverture
et là je mets le nez dehors je vois là
que nous avons en ouvrir c'est pas
possible
si les gars vous êtes prêt parce qu'on
va se faire démolir pas se faire
défoncer et puis on a fait notre premier
service comme ça avec en cinq minutes la
salle qui s'est rempli la rencontre avec
avec dominique qui est mon époux
aujourd'hui est été une belle rencontre
finalement puisque ça fait 26 ans que ça
dure je ne me suis pas trompée elle non
plus j'espère on est très différents
mais on est très complémentaires seul
selon va vite
selon va vite mais ensemble on va plus
loin et c'est prouvé
c'est prouvé moi j'ai tendance à les
vouloir aller vite je je je je fais des
choses je fonce hubert gillet je vais
j'y vais je suis beaucoup de choses
j'aime ça et c'est ce qui me c'est ce
qui me tient en fait ce qui est ce qui
motive et à côté de moi j'ai quelqu'un
justement de ne plus plus modéré plus
calme aussi qui met parfois à prendre le
recul pour réfléchir parce qu'il faut
réfléchir aussi un peu de temps en temps
il faut trouver l'équilibré
c'est comme la cuisine
c'est comme une recette et c'est ce que
je dis souvent c'est toutes les
questions d'équilibré